最高性能の古典的スーパーコンピューターは年々進化しており、
システムのシミュレーションを含む計算能力も向上しています。
しかし、自然をシミュレートすることは、一般的に非常に難しい問題です。
私はVictoria Lipinskaです。今日は、量子コンピューターで
自然のシミュレーションを可能にするアルゴリズムの一つを紹介します。
例としてカフェインを取り上げてみましょう。
これは単純な分子です。
カフェイン分子一つのエネルギー配置を表現するためには、
約10の48乗ビットが必要になります。
それは1の後ろに0が48個並ぶ数で、
地球上の原子の数の約10%に相当します。
さらに状況は悪化します。
125個の軌道があり、すべての可能な
配置を保存しようとすると、
宇宙の原子の総数を超えるメモリが古典コンピューターに必要になります。
それはスーパーコンピューターでも表現できません。
しかし、量子コンピューターには希望があります。
なぜなら、量子コンピューターは本質的に自然のシミュレーションが得意だからです。
カフェイン分子の場合、それはシステムを
160個のqubitで表現することを意味します。
それははるかに現実的に思えます。
様々な量子アルゴリズムが提案されており、
小さな量子コンピューターでヒューリスティックに自然をシミュレートできます。
そこで登場するのが、変分量子固有値ソルバー（VQE）です。
VQEは量子コンピューターと
古典コンピューターの両方で動作するアルゴリズムです。
与えられた最適化問題を解く値を見つけることができます。
VQEは、パラメーターの変分を用いた他の手法と
非常に密接に関連しており、例えば量子近似最適化アルゴリズムなどがあります。
あなたの業界や研究でVQEの応用を見つけることは
一種の技術ですが、おおまかなガイドラインがあります。
一般的に、VQEは連続変数による
最適化問題として定式化できる問題に適用できます。
これは、例えば量子化学の多くの分野に当てはまります。
化学では非常に多くの場合、基底状態に関心があります。
基底状態とは、システムの最低エネルギー状態のことです。
基底状態エネルギーを求めるために、VQEは
システムのさまざまな配置のエネルギーを探索し、
最低エネルギーの配置を探します。
大まかに言えば、VQEは量子システムの記述を入力として受け取り、
最低エネルギーを探します。
システムの配置を変化させることでこれを実現します。
そして最低エネルギーを探します。
まず、システムの適切な記述を入力する必要があります。
量子コンピューターが理解できる形式と、それを記述するパラメーターのセットを
最適化します。
アルゴリズムの量子部分は、
与えられたパラメーターのセットで記述された状態にシステムを
準備し、エネルギーを計算します。
一方、古典部分は各ステップで
それらのパラメーターを最適化する役割を担います。
この量子・古典的プロセスは
最低エネルギーに達するまで繰り返されます。
では、内部で何が起きているかを詳しく見てみましょう。
エネルギー配置は通常ハミルトニアンで記述され、
一般的に非常に大きな行列になります。
代数的には、行列の最小固有値を求めるには、
それがシステムの最低エネルギーに対応しますが、
単純に特異値分解を行います。
しかし、対象となる行列は指数関数的に大きく、
代数的に解くことは指数関数的に困難な問題です。
このハミルトニアンは
量子コンピューターが理解できる形式で表現する必要があります。
つまり、化学の言語から量子コンピューティングの言語に翻訳するのです。
詳細は気にしなくて大丈夫です。
最終的には、化学でよく見られるハミルトニアンを
量子コンピューターが理解できるハミルトニアンに変換するプログラム可能な方法があります。
次にこのハミルトニアンを
変分形式と呼ばれるcircuitと一緒に入力します。
変分形式の選択は一種の技術です。
繰り返しになりますが、
それはシステムの量子状態がどうあるべきかについての最良の推測を表しています。
この変分circuitはパラメーターθのセットでパラメーター化されており、
これらのパラメーターの初期値も入力します。
これに基づいて、VQEの量子部分は次のことを行います。
参照状態（例えばゼロ状態）を準備し、
パラメーター化された量子circuit（変分形式）を使って、パラメーターの初期推測値に基づく量子
状態を量子コンピューター上で準備します。そしてハミルトニアンを通じて評価された
状態に対応するエネルギーを推定します。
このエネルギー推定値は
古典的なオプティマイザーに渡され、新しいパラメーターのセットが求められます。
パラメーターは再び量子ソルバーに戻り、
プロセス全体が繰り返されます。
量子コンピューターは新しいエネルギー推定値を求め、
古典的なオプティマイザーは新しいパラメーターのセットを求めます。これを繰り返します。
解が収束するまでこのプロセスを繰り返します。
つまり、ステップ間の結果の差が
必要なレベルまで小さくなるまで続けます。
最終的に、アルゴリズムはその最小エネルギーを返します。
これは素晴らしいことです。
でも、これが実際に機能するかどうか、
求めているエネルギーより低いエネルギーを誤って見つけてしまわないか気になるかもしれません。
良い質問です。
実は、それより低いエネルギーを推定することは決してできません。
これは変分原理と呼ばれるもののおかげです。
変分原理によれば、システムのエネルギーの
最大の下限は常に
その基底状態に対応する最低エネルギーです。
これはつまり、そのシステムの他の任意の状態で評価されたエネルギーは
常に最低エネルギーより大きくなるということです。
したがって、VQEでは基底状態エネルギーより
低い値を得ることは決してできません。
しかし、求めている最小値より
大きい値に収束してしまうことはあります。
これは準安定解と呼ばれることが多く、
研究者たちが日々解決しようとしている課題です。
VQEが有用なのは、基底状態エネルギーの推定を可能にする
他のプロトコルと比べて、より浅いcircuitを使用するからです。
これにより、近い将来の量子ハードウェアに適しています。
このビデオでは、VQEができることとその仕組みの一端を紹介しました。
この文脈でQiskitをぜひ探索してみてください。
量子の旅はまだ始まったばかりですが、
解こうとしている問題にすでに役立つかもしれません。
私はVictoria Lipinskaです。今回は
変分量子固有値ソルバーアルゴリズムの概要をお届けしました。